il faut que je vous raconte quelque
chose
il ne s'agit pas d'une fiction
mais d'une histoire véritable est d'un
intérêt capital
cette histoire fut recueillie par Solon
qui l'entendit sortir de la bouche de
prêtres qui eux mêmes la tenait de la
déesse égyptienne Neith
ensuite Critias l'Ancien la racontà à
son fils qui est mon neveu
l'Atlantide
tel qu'il est énoncé par Platon ce
mythe est une allégorie qui a valeur de
modèle pour la société grecque
selon la
légende l'Atlantide est une île située
quelque part dans l'océan est occupée par
une civilisation glorieuse et puissante
les atlantes contrôlent un vaste
territoire en méditerranée et lorsqu'ils
tentent de soumettre les grecs une
explosion cataclysmique a lieu
leur île disparaît à jamais
en somme de la
science fiction à la mode antique
si on devait proposer une île réelle pour situer cette fable il faut avouer
que Santorin fait plutôt l'affaire
en plein centre de la mer Egée, Théra plus
connue sous le nom de Santorin et l'une
des îles les plus touristiques des
cyclades
vers 1600 avant notre ère un
séisme suivi d'une éruption volcanique
ont presque rayé de la carte cette île
nommée à l'époque Stonggylée
en grec "La Ronde"
ce qui devait parfaitement
décrire sa forme originelle
Santorin connaît toujours une forte activité
volcanique
et sa forme actuelle n'est
que le résultat de ces éruptions
successives
l'immense baie où transitent de bien trop larges
paquebots de croisière
n'est autre que la caldeira c'est à dire
l'ancienne chambre magmatique
l'éruption qui détruisit lille vers 1600
avant notre ère a fait effondrer
la caldeira dans la mer est aussi
propulsé 50 kilomètres cubes de magma
dans l'atmosphère
l'explosion a aussi eu des répercussions
sur toute la mer egée puisqu'on estime
qu'elle a provoqués à cause du
tsunami qui a suivi la destruction des
pas les crétois dont on a parlé dans
l'épisode précédent
une telle catastrophe a dû être l'objet
de récits fantastiques durant des
générations jusqu'à arriver aux oreilles
de Platon
Mille ans de récit oral de la
catastrophe ont transformé Santorin en
mythe
Mille ans de bouche à oreille et Santorin
finit dans l'Atlantique
L'Atlantide à Santorin, donc
Après tout, l'occupation de l'île est ancienne et
les descriptions d'une cité prospère et
raffinée peuvent faire penser à un site
du sud de Santorin
Akrotiri
l'explosion volcanique n'a pas seulement
dévasté la région il y a trois mille six cent ans
mais elle a aussi conservé sous
les cendres un village de l'Age du Bronze
Akrotiri est le Pompéi de la
Préhistoire
Seul site européen de cette époque
a livrer à la fois des
maisons à étage, de très nombreux objets
du quotidien et des fresques polychromes
grâce aux analyses géologiques des
différentes couches de cendres qui ont
enseveli la cité on peut restituer
toutes les phases de la catastrophe
Et il faut d'abord expliquer une chose
c'est que l'éruption n'a pas fait de
victime humaine
aucun corps n'a été retrouvé lors des
fouilles
Entendons par là que les habitants ont eu le temps de s'enfuir
hypothèse confirmée par les géologues
puisque un tremblement de terre s'est
produit quelques temps avant l'explosion de l'île
et a décidé la population à la
quitter
visiter ce site c'est d'abord être
frappé par l'immensité des ruines fouillées
deux hectares à l'heure actuelle ont été
mis au jour par les archéologues
ensuite ce sont les détails
architecturaux qui témoignent du soin
apporté à la construction de ce village
préhistorique
les vestiges des murs
atteignent parfois plusieurs mètres de
hauteur permettant de comprendre les
méthodes utilisées
les maisons très
hautes ont un système de colombages pour
renforcer la structure et la protéger
des secousses sismiques
pour passer d'un étage à l'autre
il y avait des escaliers en bois et parfois en pierre
bien loin de l'image
que l'on se fait d'un village de
pêcheurs de presque 4000 ans
les archéologues imaginent d'habitude des échelles
ou pas d'étage du tout pour
ces périodes
au-delà de ces détails de construction
il faut imaginer que toutes les maisons étaient peintes
décorées de fresques
murales représentant les activités
commerciales et agricoles de l'île
des pêcheurs, des fleurs, des fruits
des cueilleuses de safran, des antilopes et
même des singes bleus
animaux exotiques, ramenés de voyages lointains
pour les
scientifiques le réalisme de certaines scènes
est d'un apport historique
considérable
Santorin devait être à en croire le niveau
de confort des maisons
une île assez prospère
grâce aux activités de pêche,
d'agriculture, d'élevage
et de commerce maritime
et cette abondance se lit sur
les murs
oiseaux, dauphins, grappes de raisin
chèvres sauvages, roseaux, crocus, lierre et caprier
une ville qui ne manquaient de rien
qui vivait
paisiblement jusqu'à la catastrophe
par contre le développement culturel et
économique de l'île cycladique ne
correspond pas à la puissance supposée
de l'Atlantide
Santorin était prospère, oui
mais n'avait pas de flotte militaire
et n'était pas autre chose
qu'un joli port perdu en pleine mer Egée
la Crète jouerait mieux ce rôle de plateforme commerciale
puisque elle possédait une
puissance navale capable de contrôler
une partie du bassin oriental
méditerranéen
mais la Crète n'a jamais été engloutie
même si l'éruption du
volcan de Santorin y a laissé des traces
[une guide] "Donc puisqu'on est juste à côté de la mer
C'est plus bas, le niveau est plus bas
Et ici, toute cette masse de cendres volcaniques solidifiées
doit être retirée par
des futures générations d'archéologues
à la p'tite cuillère et au pinceau
vous voyez
C'est ça, qui a conservé la ville
n'est-ce pas ?"
on sait que le récit de cet épisode
incroyable s'est transmis de façon orale
pendant des siècles jusqu'à tomber dans
le registre des mythes et à brouiller la
mémoire des lieux et des époques
c'est peut-être cette réalité historique
qui a inspiré à Platon le mythe de
l'Atlantide
mais les influences du mythe sont
toujours plurielles et il ne faut pas oublier
d'où écrit Platon
l'Atlantide
c'est une mise en garde
c'est ce que risque de devenir Athènes
si elle se laisse emporter par son
orgueil impérialiste
Platon craint
qu'Athènes ne se détourne de ses traditions
tournées vers la terre et le
travail agricole pour céder à l'appel du
large et du commerce maritime
comme toute fable la morale y est
explicite
la chute sera terrible